i'm david reading for writer jordan
remay all i could really think while i
was watching the 40 minute long gameplay
breakdown for saints row was
this looks
okay it definitely doesn't seem like a
bad game it actually seems to be
perfectly sound in terms of gameplay but
nothing about saints row looks all that
interesting granted i am basing this
opinion only on what i saw because i
didn't actually get the chance to play
the game during the preview so take this
with the grain of salt saints row could
actually feel a lot better than it looks
but right now it looks mediocre as i
watched developer volition dissect its
latest open world action adventure title
the gameplay all seemed uninspiringly
familiar for the franchise i've seen
volition make this game before 2022
saints row looks a whole lot like 2011
saints row the third but prettier the
brand new setting and various new
characters at least hint at the
potential exploration of intriguingly
fresh stories but on first glance anyway
the southwest united states inspired
santo ilesso seems to be unfortunately
underutilized in saints row you play as
the former member of a private military
corporation organization called martial
defense industries you're now rooming
with talented driver nina dj kevin and
wannabe business entrepreneur eli like
you nina and kevin are former gang
members nina used to ride with the car
obsessed in fitness-oriented los
panteros while kevin fought alongside
the nightlife-loving and violently
anarchist group known as the idols eli
meanwhile is just a smart guy trying to
use his business sense to turn a profit
in the city you are a different kind of
cat eli
what can i say the world is full of
uninteresting people and i'm not going
to be one of them tired of pulling off
small-time robberies and crimes to pay
rent the four decide to claim power for
themselves and form a fourth santoi
lesso gang the saints this latest saints
row is a reboot of the franchise the
series hasn't seen the release of a new
mainline entry since 2013 saints row 4
while saints row started out as an open
world game akin to grand theft auto 3
each subsequent entry got goofier and
weirder culminating in santa ro 4 where
you parlayed your role in stopping a
nuclear attack on the united states by
becoming the country's next president
and then fighting off an alien invasion
from a matrix inspired virtual reality
this new saints row steps back from
those more fantastical sci-fi and
absurdist elements the series embraced
returning to the relatively more
grounded storylines and gameplay seen in
the first two saints row games
unfortunately that has seemingly
translated into a by the numbers open
world crime game based on the
presentation that i saw it looks like
saints row is just a series of loops you
go to your gang's hideout figure out
what you want to do next jump in your
car drive to a point on your map
complete the mission and then just
return to base to pick the next mission
the world itself doesn't seem to react
to you beyond you know the cops
attacking you if you draw too much heat
and the game features the same handful
of missions that the saints row games
have always had like
cause a certain amount of damage in a
limited time or fly to the bad guy's
base and blow it up
like as you complete these tasks you
level up and you unlock new skills and
you earn money to spend on more outfits
and weapons which you can then bring
into more missions like the one you just
completed only harder and you never
actually need to understand the lay of
the land or take note of the scenery
because the world is one of destinations
to go to and boxes to check combat seems
like it could be pretty fun as it mixes
in unorthodox weapons alongside more
traditional firearms there's nothing
quite as extravagant as what was seen in
saints row the third and saints pro 4
but there are a few cool toys like a
device that allows you to shoot through
walls and a football that latches onto
enemies and sends them flying into the
air but i'm worried that combat could
get stale after a while i watched what
combat looked like against both los
panteros and the idols and it seemed
like the same run and gun strategy
worked for both gangs despite their
members being quite visually different
and to my annoyance it seems like your
character has the unfortunate habit of
repeating the same quips in combat over
and over
while watching the presentation there
was a moment where the playable
character was fighting the los panteros
who had just stripped her car and during
that minute long fight she repeated how
she was mad because she needed that car
at least three times
to top it all off nina kept offering the
same feedback during the fight several
times too it was like an unwanted
throwback to the early 2010s when every
action adventure game did that i'd
forgive such a traditional gameplay loop
in outdated features if saints row at
least did something interesting with its
mechanics or mission structure but the
game doesn't seem to substantially build
upon any aspect of the series formula
there are more guns to buy and types of
perks to unlock but combat is still
primarily a third person shooter against
bullet spongy enemies who just sort of
rush you without a plan there are absurd
side missions dotting the map but they
all appear to center around blowing
stuff up or shooting from the passenger
seat of a car while an ally drives you
around and talks to you about something
and the brand new means of navigation
like the wingsuit aren't entirely novel
as they seem to play a lot like the
super powers in saints row 4. in the end
this is a game about steadily taking
control of a city by increasing your
influence throughout several districts
each of which is divided up at the start
of the game by the other gangs you know
just like pretty much every other saints
row game if it wasn't for the graphics
this new saints row would seem like a
game i had played almost 10 years ago
now let me be clear i don't think a new
saints row has to be completely
different from its predecessors in order
for the series to be relevant in 2022
but the lack of any sort of apparent
evolution to the franchise's mechanics
and gameplay well that leaves it looking
dated i think the game may struggle with
its narrative tone as well volition is
aiming for a story in gameplay that
feels wackier than saints pro 2 but less
so than saints road iii
the problem then becomes that the game
is too playful for a compelling
dramatization of four college-aged
adults building a criminal empire and at
the same time it's so serious that it
doesn't quite deliver enough laughs to
be a comedy if you're gonna do a story
like that think fast and furious movie
you gotta have compelling characters in
relationships that are worth giving a
damn about and saints row's main cast
has just not impressed me so far your
new allies all seem to resemble previous
saint rowe characters as well nina's
brash attitude and quick temper is
reminiscent of shandy kevin's energetic
hot-headedness and love of violence is a
lot like gat and eli's dry sarcasm and
non-gang background and more supportive
role within the team makes him just like
kinsey my hope is that these early
comparisons are a means of eventually
subverting players expectations
encouraging long-time saints row fans to
embrace a brand new variation of the
saints with a comforting familiarity
before then presenting the presumably
welcome surprise of exploring how these
saints are refreshingly different but
there's really no way of knowing whether
that's the case until the game actually
comes out
so far this feels like territory we've
covered before this new saints row seems
to most differentiate itself with its
setting santo ilesso is inspired by the
southwestern united states so there are
still skyscrapers but much of the
architecture outside the core of the
city is smaller and features more
mexican and spanish-inspired designs
the area features locations that are
noticeably less urban as well with
several districts located in the
outskirts of a massive desert and
everything is a lot more vibrant with
the brighter color palette of oranges
yellows and reds it's here in this new
setting that saints row should show the
most intriguing potential the developers
touching on a completely different
culture presenting the possibility for
new types of stories gang activities
musical expression and player
interaction to freshen up a nearly two
decades-old franchise and though i
haven't been convinced volition has
actually done that here i can tell that
a good deal of effort went into creating
the set dressing for saints row story
regardless in the end it all ties back
around to my initial thought of the game
that it looks okay we'll know for sure
soon enough even after being delayed but
scenes pro is now scheduled to release
later this year launching for xbox
series x and s xbox one ps5 ps4 and pc
on august 23rd
[Music]